well you'd think President Biden was
playing around with the old Twitter
machine with this but it's real
it reads Mega house Republican proposals
with Slash funding for border security A
Move That Could allow nearly 900 pounds
of fentanyl into our country Biden also
included his picture with a border
patrol officer the picture taken during
his single visit to a border City
remember they cleaned up El Paso so he
would see nothing happening
backlash was fierce to Biden's words
against Republicans our own Kaylee
mcinen he tweeted this must be a parody
tweet former candidate for Arizona
governor Kerry Lake said we are losing a
generation of Americans to the poison of
fentanyl because this buffoon
purposefully opened our border to allow
our country to be invaded that blood is
on your hands Joe
and here is our commander-in-chief from
December remember this
more important things to do than go to
the border the president said Republican
congresswoman from Florida cat kamik is
with me now in Focus first of all did
you see the tweet and what was your
reaction
I did Harris and I gotta say I would say
he's gaslighting but honestly I think
he's just full of you know what honestly
does he believe that Americans are going
to buy the fact that Republicans who
have been screaming and stomping and
going to the border for the last several
years are actually looking to cut border
patrol agents if you look at the
president's own budget he's only adding
100 border patrol agents we need more
than two thousand under this
Administration the Biden Administration
more than 35
000 pounds of fentanyl has been
confiscated and it's estimated that only
five to ten percent of the fentanyl
entering our country is getting caught
it's no wonder that 300 people a day are
dying under Biden's watch I've said it
before I'm going to say it again he is
not the commander-in-chief when it comes
to border issues he is the trafficker in
Chief because that's all that's
happening down on the border is
trafficking of humans trafficking of
drugs and we are seeing the direct
result play out in our communities
across America absolutely just quickly
when he says that Republicans would
allow nearly 900 pounds of fentanyl do
you think he doesn't know how this works
well considering that he's been to the
Border what once and only afternoon
he didn't see much exactly as someone
who's been to the Border eight nine
times myself in the last two and a half
years I can tell you it is a war zone it
is absolutely unconscionable what's
happening they're finding bricks of
fentanyl that have the stamps of Border
cartels in my communities all across
Florida it's unbelievable that he's now
trying to flip the script but I tell you
what no one's buying it even the border
patrol Council they fired off saying
this is unbelievable they have done
nothing to lift a finger to help in fact
they took 89 of the Trump era border
security measures off the books off the
books we have over 1.5 million godaways
in the country we have no idea who they
are and what they're doing and we have
2.7 million people who have been paroled
into our country that have a court date
of five six seven years from now do you
think they're actually going to show up
I don't think so got away is Roman free
we don't know what they're doing well
they got here illegally so we can guess
maybe they're still breaking our laws
imagine that bipartisan outrage over
Tick Tock is growing last week's
Congressional hearing put the
china-owned apps National Security risk
on full display lawmakers want it banned
let's watch
what the hearing made clear to me was
that Tick Tock should be banned in the
United States of America to address the
immediate threat and we also need a
National Data Privacy Law I think the
White House is very in favor of this
bill but into the day you cannot have
American data collected nor can you have
the ability for the Communist Party to
use tick tock as a propaganda tool
some progressives still argue against a
ban though congresswoman our Congressman
Jamal Bowman said a ban on Tick Tock is
racist can't make it up
it's a band Tick Tock is to you know put
a Band-Aid on maybe a small scab versus
what's happening in the whole social
media landscape
okay I just shake my head at the thought
of every time Democrats run up against
something they don't like it's racist
that seems to be the default setting
Harris if they can't make an intelligent
articulate argument they just pull a
race card and say it's racist that like
I said is just the default setting but
you know what's interesting is he has
135 000 followers on Tick Tock I'm not
sure what the other platforms he has
maybe he has something to do with the
fact that he feels like he will be
losing some influence if he were to no
longer have access to it yeah just the
thought of that an elected individual
that that is really sad and disgusting
another Progressive
Dead Set against a tick tock band
congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
and yes she posted her argument
on tick tock
I I can't believe this here to me the
solution here is not to ban an
individual company but to actually
protect Americans from this kind of
egregious data harvesting and usually
when the United States is proposing a
very major move that has something to do
with significant risk to National
Security one of the first things that
happens is that Congress receives a
classified briefing and I can tell you
that Congress has not received a
classified briefing
congresswoman I have to ask I mean is
this something that that we're missing
here is it a is it an age group within
Congress is it is it money as you say
through followers because that's what
that means right I mean do you need
clicks what what is it
listen it's clear that there are some
legislators up here that are just
thirsty for attention and they'll do
anything and use any medium to get that
attention but she says she hasn't
received a briefing on why it's
dangerous to have tick tock on uh on our
phones she can go down to the skiff at
any given time as a member of Congress
and read the FBI briefing the CIA
briefing the Director of National
Intelligence briefing those have been
available and I'm sorry she just hasn't
made the time apparently but let's be
clear tick tock is an extension of the
CCP they aren't harvesting our data to
turn around and sell it the way that
meta and others do which there are
legitimate concerns about those
practices that we need to address but
that aside Tick Tock is using this as a
form of asymmetrical Warfare they are
harvesting our data and our future
Generations data to use against us it's
Biometrics its keystrokes it's all the
information on your phone if you are
potentially in the future going to go
into the military get a security clear
you will be compromised and no longer
eligible to do so because you at that
point have basically given away
everything to our number one adversary
this is insane look at you hitting the
nail on the head we talk a lot about
China's military on the show and how
they have built up a Navy that dwarfs
the size of our entire military number
wise they don't have our Intel they
don't have our technology but isn't that
interesting that people who might
otherwise qualify for getting into the
U.S military could mess that up on their
CCP platform
that is fascinating last Quick word you
know I just think that it is so
important that we focus broadly in a
bipartisan way on a national data
security privacy legislation because if
we don't we are literally giving away
the farm the CCP will undermine us at
any point in time we've got to fight
back and it starts with tick tock uh
congresswoman thank you so very much
appreciate you being in Focus thank you
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights